like any other shown in anime the story
of one piece revolves around its central
character monkey d
luffy with a pirate crew depending on
him and an enormous dream to fulfill our
lovable straw hat captain displays his
might on several occasions on his
journey to become the next pirate king
and when the usually impulsive
happy-go-lucky luffy lets loose you
could probably hear us fans cheering so
let's have it luffy's top 10 showcases
of power here on vinnie tube
[Music]
we begin with the return to sarboldi at
number 10 where luffy takes down a
pacifista
post time skip luffy shows us just how
much he's progressed after training for
two years with the dark king silver's
rayleigh on his way to unite with his
crew two years after the bitter battle
of marineford luffy's accosted by marine
officer cento maru and two of his passer
fisters apparently each one packs as
much power as a marine battleship not
for luffy though unfazed he dismissed
the cyborgs for being too slow and
easily dodges their laser beams that are
targeted at his head he goes into second
gear and immobilizes one of the
pacifists with a single armament haki
enhanced blow a cool welcome to our star
of hope monkey d luffy
[Music]
taken prisoner at udon by kaido luffy
subdues the prison guards with his
supreme conquerors haki which is our
pick at number nine the tournament is
set up by queen one of kaido's all-stars
to punish luffy for helping a fellow
inmate wave after wave of tough
contenders are thrown at luffy but he
just wipes the floor with all of them
after a full day of fighting an
exhausted and starving luffy still finds
the strength to conquer out the
remainder of queen's pesky guards with
his conqueror as haki huh it's no sweat
for him despite queen's best efforts to
tame luffy the fight never leaves our
young hero on the contrary in fact it
feeds his determination and he smartly
uses the tournament as an opportunity to
train his haki this luffy is the exact
opposite of the brash reckless youngster
who was easily defeated and imprisoned
by kaido can udon really contain this
inferno with parallel strength and
confidence every time luffy uses this
extremely rare haki is a moment to
behold his display of udon is no
different
all these scenes getting you hungry sure
does for me and that's why i'm
introducing today's sponsor sakurako and
tokyo treat these two are
subscription-based snack boxes that will
give you the best and most authentic
taste of japan that you could ever hope
for for this month tokyo tree is set to
give you its take on the spookiest month
of the year introducing tokyo treats
spooktacular snacking a box that comes
with a plethora of halloween themed food
inside this box which looks really cool
on its own you get the chance to taste
some seasonal exclusive and limited
edition japanese snacks like this rare
sweet potato flavored kitkat pumpkin
flavored loaves and caramel corn
meanwhile sakurako provides you with
artisan and authentic japanese snacks
and this month they're collaborating
with the ibaraki government to present a
box that shows us another unique side of
japan in this box not only do you get
this awesome tableware you also get some
of the best and freshest offerings from
that side of japan how about trying out
chestnut snacks or blueberry manju now
the best thing about all of this you can
get these tasty snacks and a lot more
every month delivered right to your
doorstep all you have to do is start
your subscription and for a reasonable
monthly cost you can have the chance of
a lifetime to eat japan's signature
offerings make sure you use code vinnie
to get five percent off your first box
so hurry up and get those orders going
easily one of the most breathtaking
moments in one piece luffy unleashing
conqueror's haki at the summit war comes
in at number eight
at the execution of ace commander of the
whitebeard pirates son of the notorious
pirate king goldie roger and sworn
brother to luffy a full-blown war breaks
out between the pirates and marines as
the situation turns dire the
executioner's blades are a hare's
breadth away from ace's head luffy
screams for them to stop and in his
desperation unconsciously unleashes his
conquerors haki to monumental effect
marines and pirates alike are knocked
out cold in a massive radius around him
as whitebeard saying goku and the three
admirals look on in amazement it's a
colossal display of power that announces
the young upstarts arrival on the world
stage the symbolism doesn't stop there
though in that bleak moment luffy
transmits a ray of hope to his down and
out comrades making it impossible not to
see his uncanny resemblance to roger as
the greatest pirate of his generation
[Music]
at number seven we have luffy revealing
gear fourth bound man in his bruising
battle against the devilishly
charismatic don quixote doflamingo
[Music]
[Music]
with both contenders equally adept at
using conquerors haki luffy's gear
second and gear third prove ineffectual
but the man doesn't know defeat and so
gear fourth bound man makes an
appearance with a marked increase in
destructive power and defensive
capabilities luffy's attack proves to be
a handful even for an opponent as strong
as doffy at around 13 episodes this
fight's one of the longest in one piece
anime and it's a testament to how
formidable an opponent doffy is batman
isn't only one of luffy's strongest
techniques but also a striking
visualization of his never say die
attitude it's revelation not only
heralds doffy's impending defeat but
also luffy's inevitable showdown with
kaido the main backer behind the ruler
of dressrosa
it's all things ghoulish at number six
where we have nightmare luffy fight ores
in thriller park
it all starts with luffy getting his
shadow stolen by the sinister gecko
warrior and inserted into oars a 500
year old zombie giant luffy's force fed
a hundred captive shadows by a group of
renegades who've also been stripped of
their shadows their aim is to bring
luffy on par with the monstrous enemy he
must defeat to save them and himself
with blue skin a giant upper body and
enhance strength nightmare luffy is hulk
and frankenstein rolled into one it's
one of his strongest transformations to
date unfortunately it's specific to the
thrill of arc arc which means we might
not get to see it again but nightmare
luffy holds the promise of many more fun
transformations our hero might undergo
in the future and i for one can't wait
for them
at the halfway mark is luffy taking down
the yonko kaido with his explosive
elephant gun in one fell swoop
enraged by the straw hat captain for
dismantling his business of artificial
devil fruits in dressrosa kaido drunk
disorderly and in his dragon form no
less runs a mock looking for him while
everyone quakes in terror a calm luffy
chases after him on guts alone we must
applaud him catching up to the drunker
monster luffy goes into gear third and
lands a punishing fist on kaido's head
bringing down the dragon mid-flight
kaido one of the four most powerful
pirates and capable of appropriating an
entire country is no pushover and to
bring him down on their first encounter
isn't a walk in the park either but
luffy accomplishes what no other from
his generation would even dream of doing
it's far from over though between the
two and we all know a momentous final
bachelor wait but this display of power
dares us to dream of luffy winning not
only his fight with kaido but his
ultimate race to be the pirate king
what's more is a truly satisfying way to
sober up a drunk
[Applause]
at four luffy deals with the bully
bellamy the hyena
the action takes place in mocktown for
this one where the straw hats are
gathering information on the fabled sky
island of skypia true to the name of the
town luffy and zorro are sneered at and
beaten up for believing in a dream
despite the provocation the two refrain
from fighting back drawing a parallel
with the incident where shanks similarly
gets a beating in marquino's bar a
testament to the maturity with which the
seemingly impulsive luffy handles every
situation this scene's an early
intimation of the greatness that he will
eventually achieve when luffy meets
bellamy in a final showdown he calmly
dodges the latter's attacks driving the
hyena to use his ultimate technique
standing still in the fuss of bellamy's
high speed moves luffy unleashes one
furious well-deserved punch that knocks
the socks off this foolish bully
things get hectic in the third spot
where luffy faces another giant this
time it's not an invincible zombie but a
prize fighting gladiator named hajiradin
on a mission to inherit ace's devil
fruit luffy enters a gladiator contest
in disguise after taming a fighting bull
nicknamed the grim reaper luffy rides
into the stadium amidst fanfare knocking
down a throng of fighters just then he
encounters hajirudin as the crowds watch
aghast the giant swings down his shield
and leaves luffy half embedded in the
ground it's a one-sided contest the
commentator screams into his mic but is
it really in the blink of an eye gear
second is activated and the giant is
found by a haki hardened fist not many
could boast of having toppled a colossus
with such ease seeing luffy in his
ridiculous disguise one shot his
oversized opponent might be more
entertaining than intense you can't deny
his obvious power once more this winning
moment serves as a sneak peek into what
will follow in his fight against the don
quixote family
in the runners-up spot is luffy making
easy work of a hundred thousand enemies
in the fishman island arc
holy jones the captain of the new
fishman pirates is on a path to
establish the terrifying reign of the
fishmen who for long being persecuted by
humans luffy fighting the righteous war
as always is on the side of the
suffering fishman civilians a confident
hodi mocks the 10 humans facing his army
of a hundred thousand but as the
staggering numbers charge towards him
luffy walks to their very midst all
alone calmly he unleashes conquerors
haki and halves hodi's army effortlessly
unlike the involuntary haki moment in
marineford mentioned earlier this time
luffy is fully conscious of what he's
doing and he does it in the presence of
his adorning crew there's nothing new
about luffy shedding his goofball image
and becoming the icon of courage even in
the face of daunting defeat but this
early moment of heroism has remained
impactful despite the passage of time
and that's because it's one of the first
moments where we're convinced that there
can only be one pirate king after roger
and that's luffy
[Music]
and finally for our winning entry it's
got to be luffy's red rock versus kaido
[Music]
yes duck
atop the skull dome luffy joins kid
killer law and zorro to fight the
monstrous alliance of kaido and big mom
but behind the yonkos the fallen akazaya
9 catches his eye promising the fallen
samurai that he'll win back their
country from kaido luffy gathers all
their intentions within him and lets
loose his attack gomu gomu red rock is
certainly impressive but it became even
more powerful thanks to his mastery of
ryu which makes his haki second to none
even big mom's astounded to see kaido to
the ground never ceasing to amaze us
luffy declares to the shocked yonkos
that he'll surpass them and become the
pirate king this declaration of war
isn't only extremely gratifying but it
is also prophetic it's what we've been
waiting for ever since he made his
intention to fight the four yonkos clear
many many episodes ago as for his
arresting image in a long black coat
where he seems to resemble shanks or
even a younger roger is it perhaps a
telling clue from one piece creator oda
it certainly feels like it
[Music]
and that's it for today what did you
think of luffy's top 10 showcases of
power was it satisfying for you to recap
all of his wow moments tell me in the
comments below don't forget to check out
our sponsors of this video monthly
japanese snack subscription boxes tokyo
treat and sakuraku links are in the
description if you like the video and
want to watch more press like and
subscribe to my channel until the next
time this was vinnie tube see you soon